your choices you know go to a Catholic
school or get the hell out of town and
raise your kids somewhere else that's
not much of a choice at all they can't
afford to have social workers and in
deal with with the the violence and the
anger and the poverty despite spending
around $14,000 per student
Cleveland public schools are not making
the grade only 12% of Cleveland's
district and charter schools married a
state rating of excellent or even
effective what's the role of Education
in the decline of Cleveland problem I'm
actually going through a really big time
in our lives we have a four and a half
year old you live in Tremont we live
including properly lived there for ten
years and all of a sudden I'm going oh
my gosh do I have to leave the city that
I love most people aren't willing to
live in the city today if they have
children if they can afford to be out of
the city seven years ago we have 70,000
students now we only have fifty thousand
a suburb okay you're all on the cover
arguably no issue is more vital to a
city's prosperity than K through 12
education if it's bad it drives out
young families with kids and fails to
prepare young people for the workforce
any plan to revitalize the city must
radically improve K through 12 education
we asked Cleveland City Council member
Kevin Kelly how to fix the problem
what's the single biggest thing that
Cleveland to do to jack up attention
about citizen I don't have a good answer
for that
Cleveland's public education woes are
hardly unique all over the u.s. urban
schools that serve low-income minority
students are failing we went to the
flatlands of Oakland California a
low-income area populated mostly by
Latinos and African Americans a few
years ago parents and educators were as
frustrated with their failing schools as
Clevelanders are today most teachers
felt disrespected they feel like cogs in
a machine the students felt the same way
I left teaching pretty much because I
felt really burned out and had to step
back and assess David silver had a
similarly frustrating experience as a
teacher in a public school in Compton
and later Oakland then I saw the
statistic that only one out of twenty
kids was eligible to go to University of
California school and I saw that there
was an opportunity to start a new school
the Oakland Unified had passed this
resolution that ten new schools could
could start and then you could have
autonomy and flexibility with respect to
budget curriculum and staffing I said
huh maybe this is the ticket silver
accepted the challenge and co-founded
think College now where he's now the
principal TCN is a small autonomous K
through five school that is achieving
extraordinary results 68% of TCN
students are English language learners
none of whom were reading at grade level
when the school started today 60% of T
CNS English language learners are
proficient or advanced readers I love
because you know we're all a very big
the combination of autonomy and
accountability was so successful in
Auckland small schools that the school
board eventually adopted a policy they
called results based budgeting
district-wide I always say to a teacher
at our school like look I have total
trust in you to reach these results you
tell me
as the principal what you need and I'm
gonna make it happen I couldn't say that
with it we're not for results based
budgeting I'm able to teach what I want
to teach as long as I show results I
feel I feel like I'm respected as a as a
professional really glad I'm here
hey this stuff works people that want to
be innovative people that want to be
held accountable for results they're
gonna come and people that want the
status quo they may leave and that may
be okay these children give me the first
generation of college students so is
hope
Oakland has had some of the highest
achievement growth of any urban district
over the last three years in California
if it can happen here it can happen in
Cleveland it seems simple giving schools
more autonomy can lead to the kinds of
results we all want for our children in
fact it's already happening at citizens
Academy at K through five charter school
in Cleveland citizens Academy is is a
great school and I love to come here
I've been here this is can you go
basically these kids come by and large
from huff Glanville kinsman I mean
really some of the poorest neighborhoods
one of the poorest big cities in America
what kind of results have you shown over
the past few years piyo has about a 30
percentage point achievement gap between
african-american students and white
students and last year our students
overcame that achievement gap they
actually outperform the statewide
average for non-minority students by
about 7% of Japan's it's just total
difference you know they teach respect
discipline honesty and I don't think
talked a little bit about how a charter
school is different from a traditional
public school or even a magnet school
different is first of all in the funding
while we received the state and federal
funding we do not receive any local
public dollars and that works out to a
difference of around $5,000 per child
annually so you're I mean you're getting
five grand less but you're kicking ass
on test scores right do you get paid the
same as if you were at a traditional
public school you know you get paid a
little bit less so I think the people
that are here are doing it for a reason
if they wanted more money they could go
somewhere else
how do you like teacher
I love it I've been in parochial schools
as well as the public systems there is
no micromanaging here there's a lot of
freedom to experiment if I have an idea
I can go right to the top and I'm
listened to you're not part of a
centralized system you're a school
district of one how important is that
autonomy - to being able to succeed or
to try new things
for citizens Academy I would say it's
vital we have a very specific mission
here and we have a very different way of
doing things that is proven we are
trying to save children's lives here
Cleveland citizens Academy and Oakland's
think College now are proof that urban
schools can succeed so white doesn't
Cleveland implement reforms that will
lead to innovation and improve results
one of the biggest reasons is that
politically powerful teachers unions are
resistant to change how did the unions
affect education in the CPS are they a
force for good or are they a force for
bad like maybe hiring teachers based on
seniority isn't the best idea because
just hanging around doesn't make you
good I think the biggest issue with
teachers unions today is that their
lobbyists they're spending millions and
millions of dollars lobbying for issues
that frankly have nothing to do with
education what are the teachers unions
attitudes towards charter schools I
think that there's certainly elements in
the Cleveland teachers union you know
that see us as a threat
that's CSS competition and I think
that's good
hopefully it's you know encourages them
to step their game up a little
Cleveland's leaders should work with the
teachers unions to increase autonomy and
accountability at school sites even
better they should look at a promising
new approach called
weighted student funding the way it
works is that the money which varies
depending on each individual students
needs follows the child parents choose
them untraditional charter and private
schools that compete for students do you
think that that's a
vation that's worth thinking about about
having funding dollars followed the
students yeah I've heard it referred to
as the backpack approach and I really
think that it makes a lot of sense it
would be best for the parents and
families to have choice send their kids
where they want make the schools compete
against each other schools of choice are
the way to go and that's the way it is
once you get to college the future
economic viability of our city and our
region absolutely depend on the quality
of our education do you want to go to
college yeah do you know what college
you want to go to I think I might go to
Ohio State
you